yep just like my Fright Night review I'm
still amidst the great allergy attack
2011 I love her if I had to go through
this again or watch Spy Kids 4 I don't
know
Spy Kids 40 all the time in the world so
I saw this movie early so I didn't get
to experience the 40 aromascope scratch
and sniff [ __ ] however if I really
wanted my scratch-and-sniff card bad
enough I could probably find it securely
stuck to some kids PG in 1989 if you
guys don't know what that is apparently
when you go and watch Spy Kids 4 you get
this little scratch-and-sniff sticker
that has numbers on it when the numbers
blink on the screen on the movie you
scratch that number and sniff it and
there there you go you're supposed to
like smell what they smell but every
time it happens in the movie it's almost
like the scene is a byproduct of the
idea of aromascope it was like they were
like alright we need to design these
little jokes and make these little shots
and make these moments and scenes in
this movie so we can have scratch and
sniff stickers it's [ __ ] it's like
the Star Wars prequels where you look at
it and you're like yeah Lucas made the
podrace scene so we can make like 28
video games about it which is funny
because when I saw 4d aromascope I
thought one thing Human Centipede to you
baby which apparently Robert Rodriguez
thought also because there are moments
in here I swear to you the baby shits
his pants and it tells you Oh scratch
number six why would I want to smell
that that's like when you pull something
out of the fridge you're like oh dude
smell that no like what I didn't know
and that's pretty much half the humor of
Spy Kids 4 if I see one more [ __ ] fart
ur ass joke I'm actually gonna snap
so when Spy Kids 4 the clock master time
master whoever Jeremy Piven is speeding
up time so everyone's losing time so now
they got to stop them which is funny cuz
yeah Jeremy Piven and Joel McHale are in
this movie so at what point where Jeremy
Piven and Joel McHale like you know what
we got stuff going for us let's be in
spy kids for that's a good career move
right there's no need no need to do that
well in any case two new kids become new
spy kids and now they'll you know gotta
stop a bad guy but the chick from the
original Spy Kids movie she's in here
she's all grown up she's hot now that's
always cool when you haven't seen some
kid actor for like a decade and then you
see her again you're like oh dude she's
hot now awesome which is funny because I
haven't seen the old spy kids movies for
like 10 years I saw them like once but I
remember walking out of them going okay
yeah those are fun family movies this is
not like that this is just really stupid
I remember watching and liking a
selection of stuff when I was a kid I
don't remember any of them insulting the
intelligence of children
them are you know day I couldn't watch
them now but rest assured if I did watch
them now I'd be like oh that's cool for
kids like when I was a kid I recognized
Ninja Turtles 3 was not good it didn't
happen ever GI Joe apparently failed the
world because I never joined the army so
the propaganda didn't work transformers
still cool you get it spy kids just know
I went into this movie hoping for a fun
family movie I walked out going kids are
actually gonna get dumber from this
movie it's sad but it's a truth so what
this movie be a good time if you're
drunk
no I'm trash does still hate it then it
looks like spike is 4d aromascope all
the time in the world is e equals MC dog
[ __ ] I feel like I have just violated
physics itself using Einstein's theory
of relativity in the rating for this
movie I apologize Albert won't happen
again for the sake of them not making
another Spy Kids movie don't watch this
movie why would you do that to your kids
like take your kids to see this movie if
they really screw up like if Little
Billy slaps little Sally in the head be
like you know what now you're watching
Spy Kids 4 and you're gonna have to
smell the baby's little shitty diaper
when it tells you to scratch-and-sniff
number 6 Billy won't do that again why
did I watch this movie and why am i
reviewing it one simple reason to piss
off everyone who says Jeremy you need to
review the Smurfs I guess I'm a dick
it's fine
I can say that because I have to fly
down to California like at 3 in the
morning I might not get the Conan review
up until like Tuesday so I'm sorry about
that it's not like I watched this in
place of Conan I wouldn't be able to
watch Conan till tonight anyway so it's
just it's just time but if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
you